coches parqueados plazas semi vacías
buses a la espera de turistas con una
exitosa campaña de vacunación contra el
joven 19 y luego de estrictas
cuarentenas cuba reabrió sus puertas a
los visitantes en noviembre de 2021 pero
hasta ahora el resultado es
decepcionante los hoteles siguen lejos
de su capacidad y los vendedores están
cada vez más angustiados imaginaba que
para esta fecha ya hubiese un poco más
de turismo hubiese levantado a partir de
enero pero bueno estamos a mediados de
febrero y todavía tuvimos sigue un poco
rojo por el mayormente dependemos del
turismo las tiendas de artesanía todavía
no lo vemos como años atrás entiende es
una cosa que todavía nos está viendo
bien
las ventas no están como para como para
depender solamente del turismo el
gobierno cubano asegura que en enero la
isla tuvo 86 mil visitantes pero es una
cifra muy por debajo del ritmo necesario
para alcanzar la meta del país de 2,5
millones de turistas en 2022 y bueno que
tengamos los turistas si miramos la
cantidad de turistas de visitantes
internacionales que llegaron a cuba en
2021 es muy inferior a los que fueron a
república dominicana en particular que
registró más de 5 millones de turistas
pero incluso las bahamas jamaica y
puerto rico tuvieron un mayor número de
visitantes internacionales que 'cuba la
imagen de la isla caribeña se ha
deteriorado en el exterior por las
noticias sobre la escasez de alimentos y
medicamentos las protestas en 2021 la
represión y el aumento de la inflación
además las sanciones impuestas durante
la administración del ex presidente de
donald trump y que no fueron levantadas
por joe biden prácticamente eliminaron
los viajes de estadounidenses a la isla
alejando los prospectos de que cuba
pueda recuperar en el corto plazo no
perdido y se convierte de nuevo en el
destino popular que siempre fue